hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einem google gaming video
dingsbums weiß ich weiß auch nicht was
werden soll ich habe mal bei shuffle und
auch bei vielen anderen youtube
angesehen dass es diese website
existiert deswegen mache ich jetzt ich
habe angefangen einfach mal an alter was
mache ich denn ich mache die bescheuerte
begrüßung es kippt oder in der tat das
hier ist das interface der website
google folgte ausgesprochen gerade
erfahren dass es für ausgesprochen wird
ich kann gut englisch
wie gehts quasi darum dass wir eine
kategorie auswählen dürfen wie kalt
shopping ames westens und dann können
wir beispielsweise kommen klicken auf
kaltschaum jetzt kommt beispielsweise
how das google auto komplett discovery
stone nein das heißt harry potter und
der stein wir müssen jetzt quasi diesen
satz beenden wie es bei google
vorgeschlagen werden würde das problem
ist halt dass es auf englisch ist
deswegen weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht so
genau ich weiß es einen teil des
viehhändlers heißt deswegen gebe ich mal
deathly hallows ein bot ist das sucht
kein mensch harry potter andy stone
stone was das heissen stein erweisen
stone of wisdom shit ich habe einfach
nicht richtig gehabt wie klingt jetzt
einfach mal auf next round und macht mal
wieder kalt schon jetzt die pinguins a
cool gebe ich mal ein das heißt wer weiß
schon warum dann keine paypal pinguine
cool sind pinguins albert vielleicht ja
oh mein gott
green day event als will
als wenn wir alle googeln dass pinguine
gays and pinguins abhängig wie was will
ich machen pinguins abhängen krise
brachte karim haggui sah wie willst du
bit of utah dich auch kommen können wir
kriegen jetzt einfach mal auf mails oder
kommt howard scheiße wer heißt ein hort
mit vornamen der einzige den ich kenne
das wort carpendale aber ich weiß nicht
wieder geschrieben wird die klopp
carpendale k k cup an der kappe auf
wartburg howard stern
wer ist denn howard stern okay das ist
howard stern am ich frage mich gerade ob
man ihn kennen muss oder wieso ist dafür
verdoppelt trump space.com ein paar
punkte upload youtube-video drunk date
was google tier denn alle what it's like
to be gay games eigentlich immer presse
nicht scheiße okay die presse hat nicht
gepasst ich weiss nicht ober what it's
like to be cool guy like lücke kann ich
mich wie what it's like to be
married was scheiße ich wollte sogar
erst single machen
sync transformer wieso war das klar dass
das nicht geht diese scheiße auch nicht
in allem ist peter fox
dort ist ingres sofa welcher spaß
googelt ob er in so falls also freunde
wirklich ich finde es ja echt nice sowas
nein ich finde es nicht fasst was
googelt man hier die nächste sache ist
und zwar ist einfach google
ich weiß google google google homepage
vielleicht ne google wikipedia
vielleicht nie google maps
die britische google translate translate
a ich spaß google earth play image ist
alles wie konnte ich da nicht drauf
kommen indiana jones nd ich habe keine
ahnung ich hab indiana jones wirklich
noch nie gefeiert vielleicht indiana
jones and die krot haufen indiana jones
and di luca ein indiana jones and the
very big kothaufen nein auch falsch das
ist das ist ja das sind jetzt alles
diese titel aber damit kann ja nichts
anfangen ich habe aufnahmen gedrückt und
jetzt kommt's billy ich weiß nicht wenn
ich bei inter eindrücke nicht ich hätte
echt gedacht dass die leute mehr nach
kondomen googeln aber naja
billy billig kelly geborene kenny oder
so blicken
kennedy hieß der eifel having sex
vielleicht schifffahrt in haspe was
was können die leute denn girl bei jungs
wollen wohl ein mädchen sein oder
mädchen keine jungs heimischen lady of
female butterfly princess ich dachte mir
einfach nichts mehr zu als warlord also
soll laut heißt runterschlucken ist
vielleicht also nicht irgendwie denke
ich glaube ich viel zu versaut swat ist
beide vielleicht auch nicht das ist das
was ich mich immer gefragt habe ich hab
blogger schon 1000 insekten ins eck geht
nicht weil dann wird er ja entstehen als
vorlaut world nicht was heißt back dm
8000 punkte weiß wo laut was kann man
denn noch runterschlucken instituts what
appears that fakt ist dem golfball wie
ich glaube ich würde nicht mal meinem
und reinkriegen an dieser stelle würde
ich allerdings auch sagen das war es von
diesem google view video mit fragen von
google und so ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich habe wieder mal auf mein
mikro gespuckt wer das getan hat will
ich mich über eine bewertung freuen
kennt ihr solche ähnlichen websites ich
mache das sehr gerne dass ich so
bescheuerte websites auch einfach mal
zocke mehr oder weniger schreibt mir das
und in die kommentare und dann sehen wir
uns in einem nächsten video wie übrigens
habe ich kein mal nebenbei wirklich
gegoogelt also ich hab das versucht
alles in meinem kopf zu machen weil wenn
ich google hätte hätte ich auch gewonnen
ich mache jetzt pizza